wir sprechen jetzt ganze zeit über
diesem block dann der auf jeden fall bis
zum 15 februar jetzt verlängert werden
soll und bereits seit november läuft und
wir sind uns alle einig dass es wichtig
ist die zahlen jetzt zu senken man muss
auch darüber sprechen was das jetzt für
die menschen bedeutet vor allem für
diejenigen die vielleicht alleine wohnen
gibt es einen punkt an dem man wirklich
sagt die menschen halten das nicht mehr
aus die sind diese regeln dieses alleine
sein was ist da die komponente die man
vielleicht nicht vergessen darf also ich
denke mir es gibt mehrere gruppen die
man hier wirklich im genauer anschauen
muss das einmal das eine sind jene
frauen von denen man weiß dass sie unter
den maßnahmen am meisten gelitten haben
eben zum beispiel kinder
homeschooling und dann noch home office
gleichzeitig das kann natürlich gar
nicht funktionieren
und weil das nicht funktionieren kann
hat auch nicht funktioniert und war für
alle nur eine riesige große belastung
und ich glaube auch nicht dass das viel
an dem infektionsgeschehen geändert hat
denn durch den stress geht das
immunsystem in die knie und man muss ja
doch mal raus und steckt sich dann eben
woanders an
wer mir auch sorgen macht das muss ich
ganz klar sagen wenn ich das jetzt bis
15 februar mir anschauen
das sind die kinder und die jungen leute
und zwar deswegen weil schule oder nicht
schule und zwar präsenz schule ist ein
riesengroßer unterschied wenn man sich
anguckt wie viel gelernt wird dazu
wissen wir wittler mittlerweile sehr
viel
es liegt auch nicht an der ausstattung
es liegt einfach daran dass es schwierig
ist über die ferne
die aufmerksamkeit von kindern und
jugendlichen lang so lange aufrecht zu
erhalten wie das ein guter lehrer jedes
jederzeit kann weswegen ich schade finde
dass man nicht versuche befürwortet und
auch ermöglicht zb dreimal die woche
zwei stunden schule oder sowas in
kleinen gruppen mit maske von mir aus
auch bei den kleinen gehen das können
und das machen die auch mit das sehen
wir in asien und damit könnte man das
infektionsgeschehen glaube ich nicht
stärker nach oben treiben aber dafür
wirklich bleibende schäden die die
nächste generation letztlich das leben
lang begleiten werden dafür gibt es alle
evidenz die man braucht
acht oder zehn wochenschluss das zeigt
sich noch nach jahrzehnten an der
produktivität und der leistungsfähigkeit
von menschen
ich denke mir da hätte man vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr flexibilität gebracht
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren